and so for people listening who are like
okay great who's this person why are
they joining the show
give us the like 30 seconds about what's
interesting about you so chic I'm the
founder and CEO of really well we are
based in Austin we are about to
celebrate our five-year anniversary
which is hard to believe but probably
the most interesting thing about me
starting this company is I started a
company in the blood testing space in
the direct-to-consumer space coming with
no entrepreneurial background or
healthcare background whatsoever and had
every kind of in the box right you were
a consultant right Sam's all about the
pedigrees I hate it I don't care Sam's
like Harvard ok I'm interesting that
turns me on to being an entrepreneur
when I was there but certainly like I
was really on the corporate path and
then had this idea when I was working at
MoneyGram and left my job to do it and I
can confidently say a hundred percent of
people who know me was like yeah yeah so
when I was five years ago I was working
at money Graham I had a bunch of all
these unexplained health symptoms this
is super common which you hear from
women in their late 20s and their 30s as
they have chronic fatigue aches and
pains they're not taken seriously at
doctors and so I went to five or six
different doctors on good health
insurance and each of them ran different
blood tests I never got my results I
paid over twenty five hundred dollars
out-of-pocket nothing material showed up
or was communicated what do you mean
never got your result so you personally
didn't receive it the doctor looks like
even if they called me like I missed the
call nobody ever called they said
anything's abnormal well like what does
that mean you tested a hundred different
things like just because something's not
totally out of whack doesn't mean
there's not interesting or useful
information there so I sat down and I
looked at the health insurance landscape
and I thought man people are gonna have
to start paying for all that
in a more meaningful way than we are
today and I'm at least confident that my
covert of women between like 25 and 45
can't get the testing that they need
right and I think I can solve that and
to really start it out honestly not that
it wasn't a big vision but it was a
little bit like if you if you think
about the first group you're solving a
problem for that's what we lost for so
today we have 35 different tests on
every liberal comm on Amazon target CVS
Kroger we work with Humana and we offer
consumer initiated testing for
everything from STI testing heart health
food sensitivity etc basically is it
every test it's like 90 percent of
common test coverage doctor I've raised
over 50 million dollars from five from
Western East Coast feces that was after
obviously having like three rounds of
clawing my way through funding and then
suddenly things did get easier and we
actually grew from zero to see we did 40
million in sales last year yeah okay no
coronavirus but fist pound for the for
the 40 million but I'm hopeful there's
progress no I mean it's combination of
new customer acquisition and repute we
have a really healthy repeat business
because a lot of our tests are things
like cholesterol it's not recurring we
do have enterprise contracts that are
recording for Medicare right but it's a
mix of what I would call one-time repeat
and then actual recurring contracts
which is there's challenges there's good
and bad I think when you have a one-time
heavy business up front you have to
build a good set of unit economics from
the get-go so they're not just
optimizing on this like promise of
payback
right right so that's been good for us
on the other hand
we've had to be super super disciplined
in a way that I think some consumer
brands how about that right so you're
based out of Austin you do this d2c at
home tests that then get sent to a lab a
partner lab they analyze it you get the
full report it's like here's everything
here's what's interesting about this you
can share it it's like the way that it
should be like if you didn't even you
didn't have to like it invent this if
you just ask the layperson you like how
should this work that's the description
and then you just made that like happen
in real life
[Music]